et de se passer ni théâtre européen on
en parle avec anne sophie pelletier
elle est députée européenne la france en
soumises
bonsoir merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation alors d'abord une première
réaction suite à cet accord sur la mise
en place donc d'un pass sanitaire
européen
ce que c'est une bonne mesure alors vous
savez nous avions été entendu par le
haut niveau du parlement européen quand
on nous a demandé de voter sur le
s'appelait le certificat vert numérique
personnellement j'avais déjà voté contre
donc est ce que c'est une bonne nouvelle
je ne sais pas je ne pense pas je me
suis je ne suis pas rassuré parce
sanitaire qui pour moi va quand même
continuer à créer des discriminations et
qui finalement ne va pas arranger grand
chose puisque ça ne nous enlèvera pas à
la circulation du virus
on peut en être sûr et puis ça va créer
à traire à des discriminations parce que
je vous rappelle que les états membres
restent souverains dans leurs politiques
de santé publique et donc les états
membres pourront faire ce qu'ils veulent
alors vous dites que cette mesure
pourrait être discriminatoire expliquez
nous pourquoi
même si la commission propose de mettre
un budget pour les tests pcr gratuit
dans de nombreux états membres
eh bien écoutez malgré tout aujourd'hui
il peut être discriminant dans le sens
où tout le monde ne peut pas être
vaccinés donc ça c'est une première
chose nous avons une pénurie de l'acsa
c'est une première chose et des tests
pcr imaginer que les états membres
puisque c'est dit dans votre reportage
rajoute des conditions de circulation de
leur état par besoin est bien dans ce
cas là les gens vont être obligés de
faire des tests pcr tous les trois jours
par exemple en france ils vont se faire
écrabouiller donné tous les trois jours
parce que ils ne pourront pas être
vaccinés ou n'auront pas d'immunisation
donc ça c'est de la discrimination c'est
une forme de discrimination
qu'est ce que vous proposez vous au sein
de la de la france soumise pour aider à
sortir la tête de l'eau de cette crise
sanitaire
ce n'est pas déjà une avancée c'est un
jeu se passe sanitaires je suis une
soignante et vous savez en tant que
soignante quand il ya des épidémies nous
avions des protocoles sanitaires qui
s'appelle d
deux barrières je trouve que les
français ont été particulièrement
respectueux des gestes-barrières et
aujourd'hui il faut quand même bien se
rendre compte que le pass sanitaire que
l'on veut nous imposer en france est le
petit frère finalement du certificat
vert numérique alors qu'est ce qu'on
aurait pu proposer
eh bien on aurait pu proposer par
exemple si on avait mis assez d'argent
dans les tests salivaires et bien plutôt
que d'avoir des passes sanitaires comme
on va avoir en france et bien d'avoir
des tests salivaires qui prennent pas
longtemps pour avoir un résultat est là
il n'aurait pas eu une forme de
discrimination ni à vous faire est ce
que vous avez envie de vous d'aller vous
faire gratuit y est menée tous les trois
jours parce que vous ne pourrez pas être
vaccinés est-ce que nous avons un délai
d' immunité nous ne savons pas
exactement
donc à un moment donné se passe
sanitaire va réduire nos libertés
fondamentales et je lance encore une
fois une alerte parce que je pensais que
vous allez m'interroger là dessus sur
les données personnelles de santé
j'aimerais bien savoir où est-ce
qu'elles vont aller parce qu' il existe
un principe qui est extrêmement sacré
c'est le secret médical
alors est ce que nos données
personnelles de santé vont être sous le
sceau de ce secret médical je n'en suis
pas sûr c'est quelque chose qui vous
inquiète vous pensez qu elles ne
pourront pas être suffisamment protégé
par ce pass sanitaires mais de toute
façon le ver est déjà dans le fruit
concernant download et de santé si vous
avez regardé hier ce reportage sur cash
de cash investigations vous avez vu que
en donnant votre carte vitale et bien
vos données médicales avaient été
absorbée est donnée aux grands labos vos
téléphones portables avec cette
application tout senti que vides et cet
affluent qui va être finalement votre
pas sanitaire vos téléphones sont vos
premiers premier dénonciateur donc vos
données personnelles de santé ne seront
absolument pas protégé avec le pass
sanitaire est ce que ce projet lui
william un genre à part doit excuser moi
je vous écoute je me demandais en fait
si ce pass sanitaires et ne remettait
pas en cause quelque part l'espace
schengen créé en 1995 et qui permet la
mise en libre circulation des personnes
puisque sens pas sanitaires on ne pourra
pas se déplacer au sein des pays lieux
mais vous avez totalement raison
et moi je trouve ça très amusant on
essaie de lui coller des jolis mots
comme passe sanitaires ou certificats
verts numérique alors qu'en fait ça va
finir par devenir un passeport vaccinale
est évidemment qu'avec le passage du ter
et bien les états membres mettent des
frontières et rappelez-vous thierry
breton disait qu'il ne serait pas
obligatoire
et comme je leur rappelle les états
membres peuvent faire ce qu'ils veulent
parce qu'il reste s'ouvre à quelques
jours après clément bonne nous disait
qu'il serait obligatoire je le dis très
honnêtement le pass and i ter ne
changera pas les choses sur la
propagation du virus moi j'en suis
intimement persuadé le virus n'a pas de
passeport et donc ne permettra pas en
tout cas à ce que la situation
s'améliore
par contre je comprends qu'il faille qui
failli retrouver de la vie il faut
retrouver de la vie évidemment mais la
liberté qu'on nous prônent avec le pass
sanitaire n'est qu'une liberté
chimérique finalement qui piétine
largement nos libertés fondamentales
anne sophie pelletier merci d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes députée européenne la france
soumise merci beaucoup